[Music]
thank you
hi guys it's Quinn here if you
appreciate my content consider hitting
the like button it's the only way the
YouTube algorithm notices me
if you'd like to do more to keep this
channel afloat consider donating through
the PayPal Link in the description or
checking out our patreon thanks guys so
much
so recently I've been really taking my
time putting an emphasis on making
long-form well-researched content but I
also don't want to stop making shorter
videos delving into certain Concepts and
books that I find to be interesting and
compelling now some of you might
remember children of time by Adrian
Tchaikovsky today I want to talk about
another book of his called cage of Souls
cage of souls like children of time is
about so many things ecology lost
forgotten history accelerated Evolution
the idea that the Earth itself works as
a living organism with motives this book
takes place in an unspecified time in
the future where the Earth has been
poisoned to the point where Humanity now
lives in a single city called shadrapar
and outside the city due to the
expansion of the dying Sun much of the
world has become desert and some of it
has become dense Jungle full of rapidly
changing ecology and creatures
possessing intelligence that may rival
human intelligence so before we go any
further I want to talk about some
specific Concepts in this book I'm not
going to spoil the plot of it completely
but there will be some spoilers in this
video and if spoilers are a thing that
you care about probably click away until
you've read the book so when I first
picked up this book I knew nothing about
it I had read Adrian jacobsky's children
of Time series and some other stuff by
him so I really loved his work the one
thing I did know about this book was
that the main setting was a prison so
immediately in my head I thought oh this
book is about a Sci-Fi prison break
that's not what this book is about it's
much more expansive and much more
complex than that the highlight of this
book is the absolutely brilliant World
building that Adrian jackovsky pulls off
and the way that world is unveiled to us
is highly effective we start out as our
main character Stefan advani is being
sent to the island a prison in the
middle of a jungle that kind of floats
on water it's kind of a prison boat
that's huge that floats on water in the
middle of a jungle and there's really no
hope of Escape because the jungle
surrounding the prison is very very
inhospitable full of monsters and
terrifying creatures that evolve rapidly
and have a taste for human flesh so the
beginning of this book and a good chunk
of this book we follow Stefan at the
prison and little bits of information
about the world outside are given to us
by things that Stefani says because he's
the narrator and given to us through his
interactions with other characters until
about a third through the book when we
actually flash back to when Stefan was
living in shadrupar and then our idea of
the world and what it's like outside the
prison really expands we learned that
basically everything that's happened to
the Earth we did it which is an idea
that's found in a lot of science fiction
books because I think that's kind of
true and that's kind of where things are
headed we can very clearly see in the
real world the damage that we've done to
the planet and yet we keep going forward
and yet we're not really making
significant large-scale efforts to fix
any of the looming Problems by the time
that this book is taking place
it's already too late at least for most
of the Earth take the oceans for
instance the oceans are black oozing
death all life in the ocean has died it
is completely toxic to not only human
life but to all marine life and the
Eerie thing about it is that it
preserves the dead we can see what we've
done all of the fish all of the whales
all the animals float to the surface
perfectly preserved by this chemical
black ooze and there's even human bodies
floating on the surface unlucky people
that have fallen into the ocean or
attempted to swim there's a great quote
in the book The Sea is death's
unchanging Kingdom on Earth and it has
no part in this story my story is
despite all that has happened one of
Hope and there is no hope for the oceans
I mentioned that most of the Earth is
turning to Desert and the reason this is
is because of what is happening to the
sun the sun is expanding and dying and
it doesn't appear that this is a natural
occurrence it is suggested that the
reason that this is happening is because
of something that humans did in the past
some historians even think we tinkered
with the sun you hear that some great
Golden Age way back where everything ran
off sunlight until there wasn't enough
to go around and so they fooled with the
sun and that's what our problem is now
typical human stupidity nobody ever
looks to tomorrow thank God we're on the
edge of Extinction one Concept in this
book that I really loved was the idea
that the Earth itself isn't really dying
it is changing and it's not changing
consciously but sometimes large systems
have emergent properties in this book
the idea that the Earth operates as a
living super organism is brushed upon
and in its current cycle the Earth is
actively trying to get rid of humanity
and introduce a new dominant species
the world is sick of us it is turning
over in its sleep trying to come up with
something to replace us Evolution on
winged feet I didn't believe it but I'm
a bloody scientist I'm the last real
scientist on Earth
when the evidence says something
strongly enough you have to believe it
even though it goes against everything
all the Ancients ever wrote bugger the
Ancients they got us into this mess in
the first place Evolution all that slow
struggle generation to generation
millions of years all that out the
window the Earth knows it hasn't got
much time left it has thrown the whole
machine into high gear and you know what
it's after intelligence you'd think it
had enough of the damn stuff after our
messing around but the evolution Mill is
grinding towards intelligence everywhere
you look there is something doing an
impression of it everything is trying to
be smarter intelligence could maybe just
save life on this planet that's why the
web children that's why a lot of things
so this concept is fascinating to me the
Earth operating as a super organism
somehow realizes that it's dying and in
reaction to this it is trying to produce
intelligence because it knows that
intelligence is the only potential way
that it can continue to exist somehow
the Earth knows that if it produces
something smart enough maybe the
problems with the sun can be fixed
now this brings us to the web children
now I found the web children to be one
of the most interesting parts of this
book and I actually wish the book could
have spent a little bit more time on the
web children because I would have loved
a deeper exploration so the web children
inhabit the jungle surrounding the
prison referred to as the island
the interesting thing about the web
children is though they resemble humans
they did not evolve from us they are not
an offshoot of us in any way shape or
form humans and the web children are in
fact convergent evolutionary species
which essentially means that side by
side we developed similar traits now of
course the web children are a lot a lot
newer than humanity and they're only
here due to the expanded accelerated
evolution of the jungles
the web children always the web children
they were said to be like fish but
others said like frogs and still others
said they could pass for humans if they
tried except for their eyes too wide and
never blinking there were folds of skin
between those toes and between the
equally long and clever fingers that
were unlike a man's the forefinger being
the longest and the others declining in
size to form a webbed fan with only the
thumb free it was impossible to tell if
they were male or female or if the
distinction held any meaning for them if
they were children they were children of
the Damned spawned here where the canopy
obscured even the view of God
so ultimately the characterization of
them is different but the web children
immediately evoke for me the sense of
the deep ones from HP lovecraft's
Cthulhu Mythos and this is just based
mostly on appearance because they are
definitely framed and characterized
differently in this book in this book
Tchaikovsky uses the web children to
explore the what if of convergent
evolution and accelerated Evolution the
web children definitely have their
creepy moments though and other
creatures in the jungle as well there is
a particular scene with a speaking
salamander that crawls up from the
depths that is particularly horrifying
to me it's really great stuff and again
all of this this accelerated evolution
is due to humanity
possibly tinkering with the sun ruining
it causing a catastrophe and never being
able to regain the ability to fix the
sun now this brings me to another
awesome element of the book which I love
which is forgotten history now this to
me is very book of the new son Jean wolf
but that's a whole other bag of cookies
that we're not going to open right now
so in cage of souls we learn that long
ago during a time period called The
First Genesis mankind reached a Zenith
of technological progression we built
huge structures like the pyramids and
giant cities and then something happened
we collapsed inward on ourself and we
haven't been able to get back up since
then and that is what has led to the
cage of souls error where mankind is
down to the last City and the entire
Earth is poisoned and it's not just
history that is forgotten it is eons of
knowledge and science that is also
completely lost
there's really a lot to explore in this
book but the last thing for this video
is I want to talk about what happens to
humanity culturally in this book for one
the Church of the wasted God becomes a
thing and they have these nuns called
The Nuns of the wasted order and these
people essentially believe that God is
either dying or already dead they seem
to at least be somewhat anti-science and
anti-knowledge as if knowing itself
breaks the universe as if trying to
understand God's creation is what is
poisoning God what is killing God most
outrageous sin for is it not known that
the end of the world is brought nearer
every time these men of letters unravel
yet another piece of it is it not the
truth that the world grows tired of
their constant questioning sin I say
nothing but sin which is rank in the
nostrils of God if we are to save
ourselves we must cast these false
teachers these pendants and Searchers
and evil men who seek to know they pick
at the fabric of the world and Decay it
with their never-ending questions God
does not intend us to question his
creation God will return to his full
health only when these men of sin and
science have been purged from the ranks
of the right and cast into the barren's
spaces
so what I love about this is I can see
the roots of the formation of the Church
of the wasted God science technically
did destroy the planet it was misuse of
science but it was science that did it
and also the book mentions that many
images of God depict him as an old man
so they can easily as far as symbols go
make that transition from God being an
old man to a dying man so it just works
symbolically and lastly among the
portion of them that believe that God is
not dead but dying there is an element
of Hope there he is dying but not dead
so perhaps he could be healed if we
simply stop tearing at the fabric of
reality with this science that has led
us to this devastating dystopia
religions need that element of Hope the
world is difficult now but if you obey
God and you follow the tenants of your
religion you will prevail in the end
that is the idea it also seems likely
that the order of the wasted God has
influenced the culture of the last
peoples of shadrapar because shadrupar
itself is very anti-knowledge very
anti-science they send people to the
island if they cause a stir by unveiling
new knowledge it's very anti-learning
and the people of shajapai in general
are very ignorant of most things outside
of their City
so there's so much in this book that I
didn't talk about and maybe I'll talk
about in future videos stuff like time
traveling uh synthetic human beings
the underworld of Shadow par which is
literally under the ground and the
mazans the people that used to inhabit a
city deep underground that lost power
eons ago and they evolved into monsters
there's so much in this book it is a
true sci-fi Adventure novel that's also
intelligent and fun I had a lot of fun
with this one and I'm looking forward to
reading more Adrian Tchaikovsky in the
future and covering more of it on this
channel
thanks for watching guys
alright so I'm gonna let you in on my
bonus Theory so in this book it says
that long ago humankind went to the
stars and seeded the stars with
creatures like them and set out to meet
them
I think that could be referencing
children of time and what happened in
Children of time so that would mean that
cage of souls is actually
in the distant future of children of
time but it's just what happened on
Earth
definitely a possibility let me know
what you guys think peace out as I said
you can check out our patreon if you
would like to support this Channel or
use the PayPal Link in the description
thanks guys and don't forget to check
out my brand new podcast the cosmic
Chronicles podcast I've been having a
lot of fun with my co-host James talking
about various sci-fi ideas and books and
movies that I love and enjoy check it
out Link in the description
[Music]
thank you